did you know that the Mist hashira
muichiro tokito has a dark secret at
only 14 years old muichiro is the
youngest hashira he's actually a few
years younger than tanjiro and he's
already one of the strongest demon
Slayers even though he grew up in the
forest without any formal swordsmanship
training muichiro's speed ran the
demonstrate ranks and he became a
hashira only two months after joining up
this might sound absolutely crazy but
part of the reason is the fact that
muichiro comes from an extremely
prestigious bloodline muichiro is a
distant relative of the strongest demon
Sarah in history yorichi tsugikuni but
yorichi is not his direct ancestor
that's because muichiro's actual direct
ancestor is yorichi's twin brother
michikatsu better known as upper Moon
one kokushi ball if you want to know
more about this dark family connection
and about all of muichiro's powers and
abilities check out my full video link
in the description and in the pin
comment